do you become friends with some of the
CrossFitters I mean yes we're sure I
think I become friends and sometimes
they get mad at me
Brook wells is really mad at me right
now because of last year what happened
at the games and I said something in the
press conference because I considered us
pretty good friends and I said I made a
comment about stepping on the line thing
and how I thought she made a comment
about it and then I made a comment in a
press conference after the games in
response to her comment and it really
upset her and so we we kinda knees are
talking to ring the basis but we haven't
talked since then until recently until
the documentary came out this new
documentary and she just she sent me a
message saying thanks for saying that
you know you didn't want that to happen
to me or something like that so so some
of them sometimes get really upset at me
and you know the thing is like I'd say
this about that Brook situation it was
nothing what happened at the games and
even what I said in the press conference
was not nothing personal it's just all
it's it's what I'm doing there and
that's who I am there you know I have to
be I can't be everybody's buddy at the
games and I can't be on any one side
really because of the role I'm in but
yeah you know some of them over the
years because of the multiple events we
do and a time we spend together
I developed a friendship with I'd say
people like Josh bridges especially the
earlier athletes because it seems like
we do do a lot more stuff together back
then Josh you know I put him through
training when we were both in the Navy
at the same time together and yeah he
was coming through training and I was an
instructor and so I met him through that
and this is before he ever went to the
games so people like that rich Froning
I'd consider him a pretty good friend
and Dan Haley even though I gave him a
lot of [ __ ] and and obviously have you
come better friends with the guys then I
do a lot of female athletes but I do
become you know I am a friend with with
a handful of them too so yes and I would
say over the years with the new format
and that bad I travel list that we don't
have the open announcements that we
don't have the regionals we don't have
the invitational where you take the best
athletes
those were all opportunities that we
hung out and spent time together those
are all gone and I don't travel to any
sanction Allah sanctioned events so the
only time I really see them out is that
the games so that with the modern era
not I'm not as close with the modern era
of athlete the previous era of athlete
and the previous era it was interesting
because a lot of men would also be on
our training team our seminar team so
you know for like Camille
I'd consider her a good friend Camille
Jean was on the training team rich
Froning was on the training tee hee
Margot Alvarez so a lot of these people
who you know from the last generation
who are stars did book they were great
athletes and great trainers you don't
see that as much now these a lot of the
newer generation are just focusing not
competing and about most of Mark
trainers it seems and they don't they
don't try out for the seminar team so
less opportunities for me to have a
connection with some of them than there
was in the past
and also in this stage too that that
last group you know that was I think
what's happening even maybe in my own
mind so you know we've been doing the
games for 12 years it's not earlier
group I was talking about I was 10 years
younger you know closer to their age
they were 25 I was 32 so a little more
you know relatable and age and now these
athletes are 24 25 and I'm 42
so I'm also you know the gap and what we
have in common is increasing so you get
make you getting younger yeah exactly
[Music]
you